current issues faced by native americans
that's tonight starting at 8 pm eastern
5 pacific
christine king farris is the sister of
slain civil rights leader dr martin
luther king jr
next she reads from her children's
biography my brother martin
it's about a half hour
now for the parents and adults who
are here i want to give you a little bit
of background on mrs christine king
ferris
she is the associate professor professor
of youth adult education at spelman
spelman college in atlanta
and she teaches courses in
multiculturalism and elementary reading
this is her first book
and she and her husband do still live
here in atlanta
now for the little ones
you guys are going to have a very
special treat because it's not very
often that we have an author who wrote
the book come to the store and read the
book
so are you all ready
can you give her a big warm welcome
all right here she goes
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen mrs christine king
ferris
[Applause]
all right
i don't think so i think
all right we'll try all right we'll see
if you can't hear you guys wave at me
and then we'll pass her to mike okay
okay okay
well
good afternoon uh
good afternoon
okay
it's good to see you
have you been enjoying yourselves this
morning great
okay
how many of you know something about
martin luther king jr
okay all right
okay did you realize that he was a
little boy one time just like you
okay you knew him i'm sure as an adult
so
okay so this morning
now this after early afternoon
i'm going to uh read to you from the
book that i
wrote about him he was my brother
and we had one other brother and so
there were three of us
now sometimes uh children
you don't think of dr martin luther king
jr as a child but he was really
a child and grew up just like you
and so that's why i wanted to write this
book
and the book is entitled
my brother
martin
and it's an illustrated book it has a
lot of illustrations in it so i hope
that
that you'll have a chance to
to get to uh to see the book more
closely
okay so this is
part of it my brother
martin a sister remembers and the sister
is of course me
okay
yeah that would be much more comfortable
i think
okay
okay the book starts out
i was a quote some words that martin
said in
the march on washington
i have a dream that one day
little black boys and black girls will
be able
to join hands with little
white boys and white girls
as sisters and brothers i have a dream
today
and that's what he said
in washington d.c
at the lincoln memorial
okay the book starts out
and it has a picture of me
now when i wrote this book i envisioned
that i would be
reading to children just like you
and the reason i thought of that is
because
my grandmother and my aunt lived in the
home with us
and many times they would babysit for my
mother
and father
and they would sit
and read to us and engage us in
conversation
so i thought that this book would be
like a grand conversation
so i'm going to read some things to you
and so often uh
children and even adults don't think
about uh dr king
as a normal boy
and uh
who did the same things that you do you
like to play right
and so did he all right now i'm going to
to read some of the things to you
i start out by saying gather around and
listen just like you are gathered around
me
as i share childhood memories of my
brother the reverend dr martin luther
king jr
i am his older sister
and i've known him longer than anyone
else around
i knew him long before the speeches he
gave
and the marches he led and the prizes he
won
i even know knew him before he dreamed
the dream that would change the world
and now this
uh pictures
when he was first born and you see this
is supposed to be
me
his sister looking in the crib at him
and then my mother and father my aunt
and my grandfather grandmother
grandfather
we were born
in the same room
my brother martin and i
i was an early baby
born sooner than expected
mother dear and daddy placed me in the
chiva road drawer that stood have you
ever heard of a chifforoll
really
okay
well now it's like a chest that may be
in your bedroom
all right
and has anybody ever been to see the
home where dr king was born
okay
someday ask your parents to take you
over into that
the king national historic park so that
you can see
actually the home where we were born and
it's just like it was when we were there
okay so back to mother dear and daddy
placed me in the chevrolet drawer that
stood in the corner of her upstairs
bedroom
i got a crib a few days afterwards so i
didn't have to stay in the ship road
drawer
a year and a half later
martin spent his first night
in that hand-me-down crib in the very
same room
the house where we were born belonged to
mother dear's parents we call our mother
mother dear
and her parents our grandparents were
reverend and mrs a.d williams
we lived here with them
and aunt ida my grandmother's sister
and not long after my brother martin who
we called m.l
because he and dad had the same name
our baby brother was born his name was
alfred daniel
but we called him a.d after our
grandfather
they called me christine
and like three p's in one pod we grew
together
our days and rooms were filled with
adventurous stories and tinker tours
with dolls and monopoly and chinese
checkers and you can see
the
toys all around on the floor
okay
um
and although daddy who was an important
minister and mother dear who was known
far and wide as a musician
often had work that took them away from
home
our grandmother was always there to take
care of us
i remember days sitting at her feet
as she and aunt ida filled us with grand
memories of their childhood and read to
us about the wonderful places in the
world
now
and of course
my brothers and i had each other we
three stuck together
like the pages and a brand new book
and being normal young children we were
always up to something
our best prank involved a fur piece that
belonged to our grandmother
it looked almost alive
with its tiny feet and little head with
gleaming glass eyes
so every once in a while
in the waning light of evening
we
tie that bird piece to a stick
and hiding behind the hedge in front of
our house
we would dangle it
in front of unsuspecting passerby
boy you could hear the screams of pride
all across the neighborhood and there's
an illustration here you see with the
fur piece and here we are hiding behind
the hedges and the neighbors passing by
and they were frightened and you know
sometimes we were punished because one
man
he didn't like it so he went and found
my father and told him and of course we
were in trouble
okay
then
there was the time
that mother dear
decided that her children should all
learn to play the piano
i didn't mind it too much but ml and ad
like most boys preferred being outside
to being stuck inside with our piano
teacher mr man
who would wrap your knuckles with a
ruler just for playing the wrong notes
well
one morning
ml and a.d decided to loosen the legs on
the piano bench
so we wouldn't have to practice
we didn't tell mr man
and
when he sat
crashed
down he went
you see
he fell
and of course we were in trouble again
so you see us was trying to
say that we were sorry we didn't mean to
hurt mr man
okay
but
mostly we were good
obedient children
and ml did learn to play a few songs on
the piano he went
off to sing with my mother a time or two
and given his love for singing and music
i'm sure he would have become as good a
musician as our mother had his life led
him down had not let him down a
different path
but that's just what his life did
my brothers and i grew up a long time
ago
back in a time when certain places in
our country had unfair laws that said it
was right to keep black people separate
because our skin was darker
and our ancestors had been captured in
far off africa and brought to america as
slaves
okay
then we came
to we come now to atlanta georgia
the city in which we were growing up had
those laws
because of those laws my family rarely
went to picture shows i visited grant
park with its famous
cyclorama
in fact to this very day
i don't recall ever seeing my father on
a street car
because of those laws and the indignity
that went with them daddy preferred
keeping ml a.d and me close to home
where we would be protected
but we lived in a neighborhood in
atlanta
now called sweet auburn
and this is the
street and you can see
the cars have you haven't seen cars like
that have you because they don't have
any like that now
okay something like we used to call a
t-model ford and so forth
okay we lived there
on auburn avenue
and um
on our side of the street stood
two-story frame houses
similar to the one we lived in
across the street crouched a line of
one-story houses
and a store which was owned by a white
family
when we were young
all of the children along auburn avenue
played together even the two boys whose
parents owned the store so you can see
us
playing together
and our back yard
okay
and ran with ml and ad
to the firehouse on the corner
and this is the fire wagon that was
there
and it is there that fire wagon has been
restored and it's there on auburn at
that fire station
okay the thought of not playing with
those kids because they were different
because they were white and we were
black
never entered our minds
well one day
ml and a.d went to get their playmates
from across the street
just as they had done a hundred times
before but they came home alone
the boys had told my brothers that they
couldn't play with them anymore
because ml and a.d were negroes
and that was it
shortly afterwards the family sold the
store and moved away we never saw or
heard from them again
well looking back
i realized that it was only a matter of
time
before the generations of cruelty
and injustice that daddy and mother dear
and mama and anna ida had been shielding
us from finally broke through
but back then it was a crushing blow
that seemed to come out of nowhere
why do white people treat colored people
so mean
ml asked
my mother afterwards and she sat
and talked to us
and
she said
her words
explained the streetcars our family
avoided
and the white only sign
that kept us off of the elevator at city
hall
her words told
why there were parks and museums that
black people could not visit and why
some restaurants refused to serve us
and why hotels wouldn't give us rooms
and why theaters would only allow us to
watch the picture shows from the balcony
but her words gave us hope
she answered simply
because they just don't understand
that everyone is the same
but someday it will be better
and my brother ml looked up
into our mother's face
and said the words that i remember to
this day
he was looking up at mother dear
and he said mother dear one day
i'm going to turn this world upside down
i need to go on i think that's enough
now that's there's one thing i want you
to
to uh participate in at the end of the
book
there is a poem
that uh a teacher
sent to me on the observance of the
first holiday in memory of my brother
and it is entitled you can be like
martin
all right i'm going to read some of this
poem and i want you to answer me because
that poem has a refrain
and it says you can be like martin yes
you can can you say that
you can say it better than that come on
okay i'm gonna read some of these verses
and when i hold up my hand that's what i
want you to say
all right martin
was a peaceful boy
and peaceful when a man
he wanted
good things for everyone
all throughout our land
you can be a peaceful child
even a peaceful man
okay
martin was an intelligent boy
intelligent when a man
he wanted good schools for everyone all
throughout our land
you can be like martin
[Music]
all right two more verses i'll read
martin was a proud boy
and proud when he came a man
he tried to
reach
teach pride to black people all
throughout our land
and he would say
you can be a proud child
and proud when you're a man and i say
one man then
come on
all right this is the last one
martin was a reading boy
kept reading when a man he knew good
readers were needed all throughout our
land
you can be a reader read on when you are
a man or a woman
you can be like monsters yes yes you can
say it loud and strong
you can be like martin
yes you can okay
thank you very much
who has questions
who has questions from mrs ferris
nobody has a question
there's not anything that you want to
know about having a brother like martin
luther king jr
parents do you all have any questions
because there are a lot of people here
who came without children just to see
this is christine king ferris
are there any questions out there okay
well there aren't any questions we do
have one
so i asked okay her she wanted to know
how do you think
whether martin luther king would feel
because there are so many streets and
holland and there is a national holiday
named after him
okay i'm sure
i'm sure he would be uh
pleased
but he would be very
humble because he
did not want a lot of attention placed
on him
the things that he did he did them out i
think of the goodness of his heart and
he never did look
for people to praise him
i remember when we went to oslo norway
when he received the nobel peace prize
how humble he was he wasn't real testy
he was very humble and i think that's
the way he would feel
if he were with us today never looking
for praise for himself
a lot did he like to see children
oh yes he loved children
he had four children and he loved them
and you should see we have even pictures
of him playing with them so yes he loved
children a lot
little girl
what kind of toys did martin luther king
play with
toys all right uh there are some toys
here in the book that he loved to play
with
and uh see the toys when we came along i
don't think they have many of those toys
now
but we had
tikka toys
chinese checkers
um
monopoly
brother
okay do you have a brother or sister
you have a brother what was why would
you like having a brother
good well it was good it was good too
okay and and uh we
we were so close together that we did
many things together and uh one of the
reasons i wrote this book is because
people
and children because they've been told
about martin
look at him as if he is something very
very different like he came from outer
space and i want children to know that
he was just a
boy
i'm a boy just like them so you know it
was just like with your brother
okay
we're gonna take two more questions so
we're gonna take your question first and
then we'll take your question okay
my dude
made them feel better
mother can make someone feel better
you made who to feel better
i don't know
i think you're thinking that he made
people feel better and he certainly did
because he loved people so very much and
he loved it just as the question was
asked he really did love children and
you can see that each time even when he
was leading marches and so forth he was
always involved with young people with
children so he loved children
we have one more question
[Music]
yes he's still around not physically we
don't see him in the flesh but because
of the work that he did and the
sacrifices that he made
he's still around and he'll be around
people will remember him and continue
hopefully the work that he tried to
start
okay
that was a great last question he is
still around um ladies and gentlemen if
you put your hands together for mrs
[Applause]
christine king farris is an associate
professor of young adult education at
spelman college in atlanta
my brother martin is published by simon
schuster visit
simonsayskids.com for more information
[Music]